freckles broad here ah that Kenny was
out foraging at the National Park
Campground with him anyway they made it
back of course hey dials are still out
uh huh ah isla banjo boy okay we're
doing blood tie guys instead we're doing
love Todd okay I eliminate these feral
[ __ ] where are they [ __ ] how far
do I gotta go this time I'm a gas is
like a thousand years away at me up and
there we go you know it's the same old
story doesn't change much how can I I
guess I could channel they're not really
make a difference is it's like a walking
[ __ ] simulator ah let's say fat a la
la la
I could take a nigga's at last like
running lowellly guns where fuel I know
come on let's just pop this sucker go um
you know what I'm saying that JJ know
what I was I am I'm where the stupid
outfit because [ __ ] day there's like
radiation all over the fog so that's why
I'm wearing the [ __ ] Ozma at suit
their own way Trump has is a you know
nice outfit on but things are different
now I'm sure I change it you know can't
be wearing a suit out the swamp you're
getting a dirty no matter how rich you
are ok shut my deck ok ok ok ok this rot
it oh [ __ ]
hey I'm thinking about getting me of the
dlcs I don't only know kind of busy but
it is really good like way to relax at
night I just stream no stress nobody
Illinois balls nobody my balls are my
eyeballs are mine we could check book
the later okay let's say here Chomp
Chomp Chomp Chomp as as Trump tours my
character in game gets stronger as know
that oh great I'm like they let charge
up a little bit and then I'll pop them
sleep in so buddy right there good hey
leg fall he's a [ __ ] behind me know
that it that I eliminate them ready
that's my ex sugar now [ __ ] is that
I just like silently kill them look up
I'm headed I had it oh [ __ ] i missed I
care that it hey guys hit alone now that
it okay let's suck it easy I can't say
I'm here are you match how kind of
weapon as at
I know like is a big divide the
sometimes our curry and someone just
they don't from the Commonwealth I am
thank you you hear me island my friend
here is gonna even things up okay okay
at time I worked out for feral ghouls at
the campground the hero of us saga
returns it's only right you mar money I
deserve I suppose I could I've been
thinking about what's nick it never
wants something on uh huh uh yeah okay
we've all lost well we all haven't lost
someone like I still remember he had a
farm the islands and something after him
grandpa thought if you can take out that
she'll back back had a five collar up a
this [ __ ] uh what the [ __ ] and get I'd
like who shot snot on us
we switchin soon
all that like you know all the sub runs
I like Sims [ __ ] and I'm counter synth
like years and I got a better gun huh
deliver now this one's [ __ ] sucks 26
no [ __ ] ammo I likes crystal sucks
dick here hey shots on that take shots
on that no shots on that I look back and
sucks I could do the combat shotgun oh I
have like a million bullets here okay
baby we're good i sure hope i don't
encounter a bear in these parts [ __ ]
sucks out here
is that that's KITT that's good okay
okay let's go let's go that's cow shed I
should've got the perk we gonna run like
him definitely yeah a rat rabbit [ __ ]
up okay [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm just going
through I got my rat see it on I want to
go and no it's just a popping caps like
a baby yeah everything's so far away why
would I want to settle mijnheer what
sucks out here right all right I poppin
today I finally old doutzen farm where
is this night crawler what the [ __ ] is
that
I gotta get shot down here only sure
that guy let him up thank you bro that's
[ __ ] quick
he says even but I'm up
[ __ ] it I'll why
a chi [ __ ] gas a we did your show
grandpa George can rest in peace the
crawler is dead one that's another
chapter successfully concluded yes wrong
with it Felix smoke 26 huh we've had fog
crawling on against that that's right I
know I got the butter more money heroic
event I can agree to that no I don't
have to tell you I'm sure but if you ask
me that's why the last part of this time
how's that yeah I take it this is the
neck it's the final check my luscious
been Daniel was the best fisherman one
day a jail turns out some trappers moved
into the lighthouse no doubt are their
leader was having a little target
practice any sense cuz hospet get that
son of bread etc tada all right remember
trappers make ok [ __ ] where we got a
gun out you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
you have got to be [ __ ] kidding me
all right Bert longest one Jesus
sep for this though I mean I would have
to travel there anyway but after that's
at least half of another you know hard
to get to you know uh pass route one
south this a lot of running water
running in this game mmm mmm hmm
touching my ball sack baby just touching
my ball sack touching my ball sack Elia
I'm just touching up ball sack while I
play that movie theater still on oh holy
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] is it that I in Yuri's
our fight in fairies i don't know the
fastest way just a [ __ ] swim across is
getting on my half that's it on
oh [ __ ] is disgusting i have to say I'll
not drink this water the other guys are
sent to or see locked up I can I'm just
gonna run through it s gotta run uh-huh
let it cool holy [ __ ] it's jack and the
other people please [ __ ] that is a door
this isn't illusion throw Titanic okay
bay wow that's weird I not expect to say
that here
there is this amid all this like and
okay how far I gotta fall dead and what
the [ __ ] happen here yeah Richter please
you can't do this leave the Grail zealot
to you and your dedication is coming to
doubt you need to prove your faith I'm
none of my business so I'm gonna keep
moving you can't expect your stuff let's
get shot
ever set shadows off I kind of here yeah
that's it
I [ __ ] far where am I got a bunch of
crock okay what the [ __ ] is this um
hello sir I don't know what the hook
this gun on here what okay I kick on
that
Jesus
and I'm a [ __ ] what and that a [ __ ]
bomb drop on this place with Civic
League lies are so much like lightning
and I said oh I was like a really nice
place hands are pretty beat up place
gonna [ __ ] us out that works pretty girl
[ __ ] that pop this [ __ ] right here and
I lies down I guess I'll shoot him
then I keep movin because you know yeah
pick my battles you know should we come
across that Lake center right how's that
say I cliff edge oh [ __ ] is going on
here yeah these people are like a little
crazy I'm just gonna keep moving [ __ ]
all right I'm just gonna get past here
just pass a throw just passin through
all right guess it's not a running tough
[ __ ]
I know like a calendar quick save uh I'm
here for the guy that held this other
person's why are you saying him
hello how are you how are you how Sark's
hey
oh there you are
I
altair peg out there okay good good I
just stand behind here ok out that bag
Wow what the [ __ ] he says that his head
like a [ __ ] my guy up
regulus I got [ __ ] oh my eyes I did I
know I wall my Helen come on thank you
another one here yeah
a lotta Amal here though okay as I would
have any face on what's up yeah she's
got like 10 times in the [ __ ] face
chef come on come on take it take it
like a man I'm well one got weed a
couple of things here I got to get to
the shotgun and i think i need [ __ ] out
I'll do one more
hey like that [ __ ] thank that X mother
gets up here gets the critical
who's now there hey and I've just get
him just getting a bunch of air mail
babe a [ __ ] like actually took the aim
of those there what is that was
I need that ok I'll see it happens
ouch yeah that guy's disgusting a lot of
fools in these parts huh there's a nice
trip
Mac I'm gonna get [ __ ] far out of
here
okay I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
Jesus
Batman oh that was a mission
nuffin your time killing that trap make
it hurt way I've been hurting okay can
use let me tell you that trapper who
killed your husband was dead and it's
done it's finally done all those lives
now and it was no son a daughter far huh
the final chapters been written I'm just
glad it's over what now every good
storms but well I'm a little old to leap
up our face is an ending that is the
Sultan's left tilling hit the islands
nose and that's it off you dumb [ __ ] is
this dicks out for her Rob